So, six months ago, I get an email from Stewart Butterfield...
...who wants to talk about making a video for his new thing, Slack.
It would change the way teams communicate.
The truth is, I was spending all my time doing emails instead of making stuff...
...and something had to change.
So yeah, we tried Slack.
Slack lets us do all our communication in one place.
It's like combining multiple forms of messaging and file-sharing into one app.
You make channels in Slack, which is perfect for discussing specific topics in groups.
Slack integrates with Dropbox, which is amazing because we use Dropbox for everything.
I like that Slack always keeps my place.
I can switch from my laptop to my mobile and I never miss a thing.
Is this your card?
Yes. No.
And Adam loves it.
Slack really has changed the way his team communicates...
...and all this open, efficient communication keeps his company happy,...
...which makes Adam happy too.